[Music]
oh my god I can't believe this I got a
new home a Sega this game for Oh
[Applause]
and what a fashion these last three
games didn't even seem close liquid they
had something go for themselves
but then they hit the brick wall oh
Jesus I love the best team in the world
man what an unbelievable international
if hoji weren't already the greatest
Oregon dota history they definitely are
now but no tale and the boys making an
unlikely repeat was not the only
exciting thing to happen at TI not from
the hype casting calls to the
jaw-dropping plays to the 200 IQ
turnarounds the International 2019 was
chock-full of memorable moments
so to kick things off we're gonna take
you through the flashiest and most combo
intensive plays to happen at ti9
if infected the something officer play
around at AZ slow in life he'll try and
hit your ride inside of s foley at the
hell out of here
burrowstrike in one second with the
banner they got taken away by the mystic
snake they have to pop out they have to
fight at least you'll be able to get one
die back over on the Tosca
Oh maybe even a triple kill for rtz he's
just had this crap off ultra Cal given
the rampage to pass yeah that's
dangerous oh my god they got it
the chronosphere comes out it's on
absolutely everybody head white but for
with it are you kidding me to chalice
walks in takes down one now the aleutian
shows up are they gonna be able to find
that kill afterwards gets and DD with
the Earth's what are they by back down
to one chalice need to walk away is
eventually gonna be brought down
sanity's equips don't do it cool that
fly they can't handle it and they're
eventually gonna kill him off somnus eat
the dirt no buyback was PA even in that
[ __ ] he didn't need the beat was all
FY and they have the both be applied and
chris locked people to take him down
the earth splitter off first now
Scofield snow JC may get the ice blast
on the season see tornado or a wet
scenario and Chris Vaughn why did for
the Bullock it quite gets their policies
in ravage to get the turnaround and they
do manage to catch the slark whisper
down
[Applause]
he got his buddy out of trouble Chris
[ __ ] though is he gonna be so lucky CCNC
gonna throw up infamous down baba
they're looking for set soon there's
gonna go for the colonel again a twelve
played by boxy as that one is just going
to be a quick and easy kill Oh
[Applause]
I think right now taka does more damage
if she's gonna zakat and rub the traitor
guard that's
yeah they just need one here to be lost
in D car comes close he doesn't have
flame cut off just yet so Kaka picks him
up first back down it was the Avalanche
a quick instead keeping atmosphere
rooted here comes the massive Bergy he
got ripped on the backside it's down to
your back don't whispering it's under
the
to be able to finish off those
amendments passed by backs coming out
there trying to say picture half health
doppelganger away mid one jump same club
now
and that's so bad he didn't get off the
bishop and that gun on the hectare the
arrow
miracle though it's so hot to go for
road shine against DT HP senator is dead
and looking for this notice I need yeah
you Lotus to the virus right tiny cell
volts up to trouble here he does have a
Tulsa me what's turn use that go slap
catches out three miracle absolutely
destroying them he's got the Maldek
gonna lose go take a lot of damage here
all chicken is just holding his granny's
life sitting back up as well baby that's
great he gets delay in there cool oh
that damage force to infest
no no no way that kook Timmers that
Tim's is isolated on the side Tim's whoa
full Armel still looking at trying to
get in he's gonna look towards rip on
nipple goes with the magic the engine is
still alive that's the tractor back bit
what bullseye turns to Ward's arm out
did you get these kills his niece is
just trying to hold his ground but Kathy
with the rage heads for Yap so Yap so
sad
for Ganesha died they're turning the
stop Gabby's in trouble Kathy shut down
his pista with the triple kill
and he may not be done yet the body
cards come out but it was learners to
Todd Miller to Cooper that's gonna be an
ultra kill he's gonna guarantee please
just shoot the ball Leisha it's got a
gun no gun it sighs I still to wrap a
tie
come on sighs come with that that's just
not cool haha but dude get them all
jumpy to the backwards and easily just
back up the whole his teammates the BK
the ogre
a good distraction but eg what can they
really get out of it Oh coal down on top
of the ramp tempers ball but a hand
comes out up going also about TV where's
the art but it still flies going down he
just town take this boggle bike and now
the jump in bro
jarick controlling smell the backlights
this dirt will be kv mr. Poirot
TV : life does not have the Sun de
arriba killed him with a brothel
with notable apps jharikhanda doesn't
have enough power her chief will not let
up in something like a cake inside your
face I remember doing this in Game two
he does have a buyback he tries to use
it the two minutes give the Stuart back
of the tier force but Hannah's super
tanky all what Laurie just pasta down
that's a triple kill for him and it
looks like cevaz over a yang looks feel
to finish that one off as well
Ori he did it he showed up big time the
top
[Music]
personality don't actually hit up the
outlet covers the crowd without people
maybe he's trying to get the bathtub
to the chase they go
it's actually modeski aren't able to get
something out of this but maybe he could
stay alive
he's a tier 3 he will trick hell for me
why we're just watching him go back and
forth here fully healed as the underlord
it looks like a punching bag just
hitting him over and over can they oh
[ __ ]
and he gets it off onto three of them
there's gonna be one kill they're gonna
be two kills there's gonna be a third
almost there it is Topsy ready to go
it's gonna wait out the ice path thank
you fling forward toss back on us on
this or you can look for more these can
look for more insert he's gonna grab
what a sick combo emoji is the gg
spent picked up his BKB not even gonna
bother at this point he understands how
this game has been
I Nina could have said it better right
with this chat wheel
sorry crowd where are you excuse me
where you at I don't hear you they
didn't stand a chance and Chris them
down they don't have gets the cheese off
we've been talking a lot about our TA
having a hard game but as far cpg goes
their other two parts are not looking
too shabby
gyrocopter almost talking net worth over
is ahead of the Enchantress here we go
again
cost me
don't tell the elf especially when s4
blanks into a creepwave Chum Ford finds
- that's a good tunic gap at the and
that's Guardi proc print living through
this one trying to find fall it's gonna
be there
it's not enough they're trying to run
away is it gonna beat up the brake to
catch the control you time ups out of
there
got the dog
deep secret god damn
[Applause]
October forward he made a basket for
next up we're gonna take a look at the
most big-brained [ __ ] to happen on
DotA's biggest stage to date seriously
sometimes you need to rewind them just
to appreciate them take on a for
instance who waited until after RTZ
bought his Eagle song before hitting eg
shrine and revealing his freshly
acquired MKB mkb got completed already
do you still go on TV in for the
butterfly I think you might want to
change this plan now and go Scotty I
think now it's I don't think he's like
in the quick why he still has caught a
fly is he gonna fire the eco song as he
walked past yesteryears okay so they say
didn't get the information on Hanah
he doesn't have I back now that's fold
and this really is the principle of
getting kills into objectives right is
that no tail they understand it's the
same thing and he's saying you can kill
me but if you're not taking the rather
it's fine it's on the run there please
pinging towards the people I think about
this right now the turn comforts of the
melee creep is gonna get denied illusion
rune while simultaneously pulling all of
this into Anna Sewell I'm gonna return
it back slaughter late this is some
next-level [ __ ] from og oh my lord
I can't even believe that he dragged him
to hire creep wave so that Anna gets a
double wave in mid lane he saves the
bottom Tower baby wastes his entire time
and he denies the illusion room to allow
you single creep that I've seen about
his rotation OD needs another Astro
stone cool down for a few more seconds
up IRA or Denis cough the OD just before
the astral imprisonment came back up and
miracle gets jus tear duct runs back up
to the north a miracle knows this he is
gonna Scott him out in just a second oh
he completely breaks his ankles doc has
managed to Juke miracle himself
disrupted now trying to walk away still
lay before the moment a long-duration
silence the birth strike coming through
they try and keep the spectre alive
they're jumping back and forth through
the e plate keeping them alive dots the
room left
but nothing at all
- out of mana my god they couldn't get
him useless wet down bottom and set up
on to mind control he hasn't got the
stomach for a couple of seconds phages
looking for him stick charges will be
that warm alright that will do it so I
get the first strike home
oh you touch the stun I can't him these
things should happen
ooo the jukes no way wait out another
petticoat where did he go nobody knows
the Jews are real he's out in the trees
Montreux we'll manage
TP away they're going down as well they
popped BKB for mid one still looking for
the chase they take down side he buys
back 5f coming also for
we all under fire maybe the crowd
feeling a little bit of a sign of life
but they can make it happen
the Sun is gonna come out in just a
moment they find themselves this et the
boats gonna land now what more do you
have left in the take is the Bristol
back is gone
hi again secrets base though they've
lost one of quite a bit ago in the
second ones down to 1/4 age they just
focusing on getting a brochure which
they will get what a beautiful snatch
their the chasing for we are as well we
are it's good CP and chunky by the
century he puts a century into the trees
who is this guy you can see once it
fades she's dead he is just dead and
Margie turn four oh he goes for it up it
does he get honey got pink on it he got
the killer ocean oh my god nostalgic
when it comes to dota few things are as
satisfying as watching a caster
absolutely lose their minds whether it's
a one-time teamfight or a comeback
against mega creeps our next section is
sure to get you on your feet zero
seconds creditors I'm going to go
through these
he's a diver
it's
feet gonna be tasty Neko baby's already
blown his beak baby stays these secrets
they say--they she was a fighter
anytime
we actually minutes attention it all
can't get away
wait for me son he's trying to finish
this up dive into live they need the
vaccine Evo Gitmo he's gonna be able to
get the booty
he's dead
Jeff with three
he can do it they're gonna be able to
write down in
tips retail has been beat down here we
go again loans done on the outer panel
members got the agency model but it's
the Lord cooldown abilities climb
getting smacked in the
that tree had thistles sad paparazzi
says it's time to come back the
reinforcements are here the call has
been made a cheat gaming could have just
kite out an eel slowly tick away over
there just make it into the mine
Thursday please no Jarek save us
anything but vici gaming gee they got
wipes but the least they brought me
cheeking down with what a pain die he
may be in trouble as well but eco people
don't want to extend himself he knows
Vegas eats the focus moon looking to be
able to finish off that retracting
should be able to get the Sun fights
goes off defensive or snap boom Kobe
back they woulda became he tried to get
those people I see
get away with the arrow Dale
secret now they have to upgrade the
Mineski will feed their lies away off
the greater good but now it's gonna be
the arrow coming out on denisa control
the crepe rail line the cast Nico baby
trying to finish Bob that's gonna be his
first life second line coming up for him
and the outfits on table concoction
ready to go on the meatless enjoying the
buck KP protecting where the hefty great
Logan
he may also fall
not quite enough with siphoning out it's
actually going to live through this -
Zico baby his guitar
these are fights through it all
my back my back but everybody else can
all it takes is one fight the tier 3
secret and there's no good either boot
to the tier 4 holding
they're gonna try and make sure the
rates of potatoes well Pete hey Pete can
still buy back
Vico baby he's gonna make his jump board
he does have those extra lines but he's
probably gonna need involved the United
I so fat head turner KB buys back which
is five seconds left in the clock can't
get there in time fitting actually saved
Nico baby's gonna love his meat babyrage
baby who's going forward eat something
gets controlled up and does heavy gold
set for another week way they're trying
to finish mom heels coming out KP can't
provide enough go the fear of life
doing that before
they do the melody with the death will
come out from them
now as we all know TI isn't just about
great dota
it's about hopes dreams and well the
biggest prize pool in all of eSports our
last section is dedicated to those
moments where real life and dota life
came to a head those moments that hit us
right in the fields and made us remember
just how much is on the line for these
players but Before we jump in be sure to
LIKE the video subscribe to our Channel
and let us know in the comments what
made this ti especially memorable for
you see you next year do you have
anything to say to your friends you've
got a lot of fans in all different
regions what do you want to say to them
[Music]
be happy yeah I mean life good you I did
alright short but sweet
I think disappointment maybe doesn't
believe even begin to cover it
Paul I'm here with with fade and I know
emotions are running high so I am gonna
give you the microphone this is your
platform you guys had an amazing run and
I know this wasn't where you were hoping
to end up on but this is your time
that's your camera
yes all I wanna say is that since first
class and it's like our pharmacies ended
but maybe left goes ah so so it's fine
so we were happy back next year maybe
we'll be strong it's a game that I truly
love and I'm sure that I'm not the only
one there's so many players the good
parts again focus on the positivity
enjoy the games
enjoy your teammates don't queue for the
next game if you're in a bad mood and
you know it's gonna be a bad game queue
if you're looking for the fun if you're
looking for something good if you're
looking for that nice game or nice
experience and that doesn't mean winning
some of the best games are still
spending and yeah some people get caught
up in that as well play for play for fun
have fun enjoy it good a great story for
them and obviously all the respect in
the world for their competitors team
secret
you love to see it like I said there's
just so much respect and admiration
between these two teams
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're here before this tournament
thanks for a bit dark my dog had died
and yeah was really rough a couple weeks
my my self-esteem was pretty low and
[Music]
over here
a Sebastian I mean honestly I dedicate
this tournament to him
no but really Thank You Sebastian and of
course and everyone else just feeling so
[ __ ] lucky if you think so [ __ ]
good
here we have it the team I believe
preparing to lift up what is rightfully
theirs for the second time in a row
there
sab himself
so leading the crew
you cannot help but be awestruck by what
this team has shown us in this entire
run in these two years and now for the
grand finals ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]